the Joe Rogan experience now the crazy
thing is that this probably could be
fixed with legalizing all drugs but
nobody wants to legalize all drugs it's
such a catch-22 because like if you had
heroin available at the corner store you
would have no need to buy fentanyl and
if it was like at a reasonable price
where they couldn't undercut you like
hey heroines five bucks something for a
dollar yeah it's it's a terrible thing
to even say I don't want people to be
able to just go buy meth yeah well the
way to think about it I think is like
decriminalization a lot of times is like
a better alternative in my opinion in my
you know my research and then
legalization right so like the
presidential candidate Andrew yang talks
about decriminalizing opioids right and
so when I first heard about that I was
like what I was like that is a bridge
too far but the more you think about it
it's like people get arrested for using
fentanyl they go to jail and then the
recidivism rate is like through the roof
people like get out and they start using
again they don't get the treatment they
need you know and so the opiate you know
like people don't realize that fentanyl
is killing more people than any drug in
American history ever on an annual basis
more than heroin more than pills more
than math more than crack and so things
just get worse and worse every year
people aren't talking about it that much
but how is decriminalization going to
stop that because decriminalization will
just make fentanyl more available the
point of legalizing all drugs and again
this is a very very messy subject and
I'm not a proponent of legalizing all
drugs I'm sort of agnostic on and I'm
like I don't know I don't know what the
[ __ ] is it what is the answer but if you
legalize them and you can buy them from
reputable sources you would know that
you're actually buying cocaine you're
not you're not buying some fake Chinese
spice Jamyang whatever the [ __ ] they
call it you're buying actual cocaine and
you look we know if you buy whiskey
you get a thing on the label it tells
you what proof it is you know that if
you have yeah you know three drinks
you're gonna be [ __ ] up and we can
regulate that we could sort of adjust
like I had to already I'm good you know
but if you don't know what's in it you
don't know what the dose is so you don't
know what you're okay with and what
you're not okay with one of the good
things about alcohol like you get a beer
that's a beer you know what that is
yeah you know how much alcohol is in
there yeah well in some countries in
Europe they actually give free heroin
and these are addicted users yeah and so
that you know it's often not the heroin
that kills people at all it's the dirty
needles it's the criminal lifestyle used
to like pay for the money to buy
prostitution things like that and so I
went and visited these places called
supervised injection facilities if you
heard about these yes yeah where would
these where do they have them well they
don't have any in this country is this
one in Philadelphia yeah and there was a
court case in its favor recently the
former governor ed Rendell is like
spearheading that but I went to one in
Barcelona and so these are places where
drug use is totally legal inside the
facility they have clean needles they
have doctors and nurses supervise it and
and they even like so they have like
this the smoking-room where you can go
and do do anything you want
they have crack pipes like that the
government provides they're like
government-funded and created crack
pipes that they'll hand out to people
and they've never had an overdose death
in one of these places they they have
they're connected to treatment centers
they gave out methadone suboxone all
these treatment drugs it brings people
into the system so that they're
accounted for and these have been like
super successful but in the u.s. there's
like federal crackdowns on them you know
I again it's I think there's an issue
politically right because nobody wants
to be the one that says hey we're gonna
open up a place where people can come
and shoot up yeah and people like will
[ __ ] this guy my sons hook
on heroin this piece of [ __ ] wants to
help him you know what we need is detox
center so we need his treatment we don't
need a place where you can go and shoot
heroin you know but like many things in
life
this whole heroin thing fentanyl thing
all these different it's very messy yeah
well so even if you're not going to go
that far there are simple steps we can
take to help stop the opioid crisis and
one thing I'm a big advocate for is
called fentanyl testing strips and so
that's the weird thing about fentanyl is
it's not a demand driven drug like every
other drug it's out there because people
want it people want cocaine people want
heroin people don't want fentanyl
sneaking it into other things exactly
and so studies have shown that if users
know fentanyl is in their cocaine or
their math or their heroin or their
pills they will be much less likely to
use it and overdose up from it and so
fentanyl testing strips they're they
look kind of like pregnancy tests
they're really cheap just these paper
strips you mix up your solution of
whatever you think you have heroin and
you dip the strip in there and if
there's two stripes that means that you
have fentanyl and if there's one it
means you don't or else the other way
around mm-hmm and so it's it's simple
it's immediate but but again u.s. laws
are so insane that these are actually
banned in certain states like
Pennsylvania so that could be done to
help people understand there's fentanyl
and the drugs that they're looking for
they're looking for cocaine looking for
heroin
turns out this pencil in there
[Applause]